yo yo bienvenue dans cette vidéo dans un
décor qui n'est absolument pas c'est pas
chez moi on n'est pas chez moi on est
bas je veux pas pourquoi tu dis ça parce
qu'on est chez moi on est chez toi
exactement c'est le sait le principe ça
commence sur un bon petit mind fuck
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça c'est la
chaîne de mind fait qu à sa bienvenus si
vous connaissez pas le rap philo deux
allaient l'écouter tout de suite soit
parler du rapido deux ans suivant il y
aura tout un tas de spoiler donc allé
voir la vidéo parce qu'on est là pour
les explications qui ne s'en découvre
après exactement c'est un rap
philosophique qu'on a fait sur la chaîne
de paix
exactement est-ce qui dès qu'ils
démontent et c'est le deuxième volet
puisqu'on en effet un l'année dernière
et on a recommencé cette année mais là
on va plus loin en loin parce qu'on
explique à on n'explique pas ce qu'on a
vu la première version et des trucs que
les gens comprenaient pas forcément du
coup on met la main à la pâte
c'est à dire qu'en fait on retrace avec
haut à 2503 milan de pensée de réflexion
très complexe en trois minutes
donc il ya un petit avec la contrainte
de voilà de la rime de la rime du texte
donc c'est pas évident ouais ouais c'est
en fait la difficulté on y reviendra
tout du long mais la difficulté c'est de
jongler entre la mélodie cité des mots
et des phrases et l'exactitude des
concepts alors est parfois on est sur le
fil
on a essayé de faire aucune faute grave
même si il ya des approximations et
forcément les approximations mais en
tout cas voilà on va prendre un petit
peu plus de temps pour donner des pistes
en tout cas pour aller plus loin parce
que même en 10 minutes ou quinze minutes
c'est ça on va durer la vidéo on peut
pas faire le tour non et c'est pour ça
qu'il y aura beaucoup de renvoi parce
que c'est des trucs qu'ils ont
déjà été traités soit sur cette chaîne
soit sur d'autres donc on va pas hésiter
à vous mettre des îles des liens enfin
par ailleurs à julien à gogo il y aura
du lien au cas où il y aura l'url si moi
je m'appelle epicure je ne suis pas
celui que tu crois il profite des choses
de la vie des choses matérielles c'est
pas non plus vieux l'eau comme il écrit
sur mon tee shirts et pas n'importe quoi
donc on voulait resituer ça c'est ça
j'suis pas un profiteur pas un homme dès
que c'est souvent les gens me disent
carpediem ils confondent l'idée de
carpediem avec avec le viol auront fait
avec voilà exactement
je suis vraiment dans le dans l'hôtel je
vais dans le terrain alors t'as pas
compris mon hédonisme je vais pas me
vexer l'hédonisme c'est un thème
important lit à epicure via epicure
exactement viens dans mon jardin grecque
alors grec évidemment c'est pour
resituer le contexte
epicure était grec le jardin c'était là
où est peter enseigner le jardin
d'epicure l'ataraxie sept prochains mots
clés c'est l'absence de trouble de
troubles exactement d'être derrière ces
termes là il ya une vidéo sur cette
chaîne sur epicure que je vous mets dans
inscriptions qui retrace toute la
passion des piqûres donc que je vous
invite à regarder exactement même moi
même je vais regarder on arrive sur la
classification des des yeux des désirs
et non pas des démesures c'est quelque
chose qui est important dans la pensée
des piqûres
j'élimine ce qui est vin le vin ça fait
partie des trois en fait voilà dans la
d3 alcool il ya les plaisirs 20 et
désire vin naturel et nécessaire à ceux
qui sont naturellement nécessaire ceux
qui sont naturels est nécessaire que
d'un tas d'autres tableaux qui sont
hyper bien fait matérialiste
c'est un terme qui est pas anodin non
plus mais alors matérialiste en gros
c'est que pour lui tout s'explique
tout est matière un peu l'âme par
exemple c'est de la matière et les
contenus dans les atomes
voilà c'est ça tous et toutes et
matières quoi par opposition à idéaliste
oui matériel et c'est un terme qui est
galvaudé aujourd'hui qui a perdu son
sens là ce sera mais quand on dit
quelqu'un c'est matérialiste et un
profiteur un flambeur on pense qu'ils
pensent qu'à la thune alors que matériel
ça là bas c'est juste pour lui tout est
matière ensuite bon il ya un couplet
blagues sur
baruch manger directement sur les
philosophes mais ça me semble important
de dire que baruch et baroque
c'est pas juste gratuit oui c'est vrai
qu'on s'est rendu compte que ça ouais il
a vécu à l'époque baroque exactement
puisque c'était au milieu du xviie
siècle mais de mémoire ouais spinoza
donc spinoza alors pareil il ya pas mal
de concepts que que vous pourrez
retrouver sur cette chaîne et radio que
j'ai pas traiter et je vous mettrai des
liens d'inscription donc familles
portugaises juifs issus de dames donc
dams et amsterdam
voilà dans le langage des jeunes
exactement il vient du xviie siècle
père mère frère petit j'ai tout perdu à
il a eu une vie pourrie ouais ouais
ouais
certes il a perdu beaucoup de son
entourage et il a été ensuite excommunié
chasse et lynché renier de ma commune il
a passé sa vie à écrire les tic
il n'a pas écrit que ça mais c'est une
oeuvre monumentale dont il a mis
beaucoup de temps à créer et à écrire
pourtant pas de fric mon lait plein de
tics bon je sais pas s'ils sont liés
avec des tic mais en tout cas il n'avait
pas d'argent il a vécu une existence bas
misérable ouais le pauvre petit chou
mais se plaignait pas de sa situation
c'est pour ça qu'il dirige pas
pathétique
non je rappe malgré mes malédiction
parce qu'il s'est fait maudire par toute
la communauté juive mais elle a
excommunié mais aussi rap est pas
vraiment exact où il rappelait pas
vraiment c'est important le préciser
quand même l'éthique de ce mois que ça
parle pas que des tic exactement
on va déterminer sur un terminé causes
conséquences est terminée parce qu'un
déterministe pour lui tout s'explique
tout est un enchaînement de causes et de
conséquences voilà en gros je vais faire
une action parce que il ya eu des causes
que je vais faire cette action
l'intelligence c'est la volonté qu'on a
tous parce qu'en fait il rapproche le
concept de volonté et d'intellect je
vous mets un lien qui vous expliquera un
petit peu plus pourquoi mais le malien
pardon ce qui est content a lancé ce qui
peut ne pas être
l inverse de ça c'est la nécessité et
pour spinoza ce qui est nécessaire c'est
dieu la nature un dieu et la nature
c'est la même chose pour spinoza et donc
c'est la fin de mon 16-16 c'est dans le
rap c'est cesse vers exactement et c'est
si tôt voilà ce que je vois du
déterminisme de spinoza s'opposent
complètement bien sûr à monsieur jean
paul sartre donc on fait un bond dans le
temps on arrive au 20e siècle et est
notre ami jean paul il dit exactement
inverse
sur ce point précis on va voir ça tout
de suite on va reprendre les choses dans
l'ordre
jean-paul communistes parisiens hop ça
c'est des infos toujours utile sean paul
ça n'a rien à voir mais parce qu'il
était communiste à temps oui vraiment
ouais ouais enfin le communiste du parti
communiste on a dit qu'il était un
humaniste alors sa pensée est humaniste
c'est même le titre de son livre le plus
célèbre qui et l'existentialisme est un
humanisme
alors cette phrase pour moi était très
longtemps obscur l'existentialisme est
un humanisme
ça signifie que sa pensée qui s'appelle
l'existentialisme parce qu'elle met au
centre de tout l'existence c'est à dire
le fait d'être et donc le le fait de
vivre et de faire des choses elle met au
centre de tout l'homme puisque en gros
en s'opposant au déterminisme en anglais
et de sartre il dit pas on n'est pas
forcé dans la vie on fait des choix tout
le temps et ses choix du coup ça nous
donne une immense liberté ce n'est
phrase c'est voilà l'homme est condamné
à être libre de ses choix et cette
liberté qui redonne le pouvoir à l'homme
est humaniste parce qu'elle remet
l'homme centre des choses
l'existence précède l'essence c'est la
pensée schématiser de sartre en trois
mots c'est un peu je serais mal le faire
mais en tout cas je sais que tu as fait
une vidéo dessus du vide au dessus on
invite les gens à aller voir la vidéo
justin minimaux oui sur le quartier
latin en fait parce que sartre et
beauvoir et passait beaucoup de temps au
café de flore etc qui est dans le
c'est un quartier de paris quartier
latin c'est un quartier de paris rennes
ou latin et sean paul latino voilà je
oui le ton et d'esprit ça fait le trait
d'esprit valait le coup d'être
explicités rap genious on peut on peut
le dire aussi que les gens ont échappé
aux lapins crétins
oui c'est vrai mais n'a pas réussi à
mener l'attaqué d'un moment il était là
en train d'écrire mafieuse là d'un
crétin incroyable solo nous passions à
le garder mais incroyable emmanuel kant
ok donc ils débarquent de l'allemagne du
xviiie dont 10 ème siècle c'est le papa
de la pensée qu'ancienne c'est sympa
tout court du game on peut le dire
maintenant c'est un peu le boss final de
la file ces voix là il ya un avant et un
après quand il a traité il a traité
énormément de sujets il a tout repris ce
qu'avaient fait les anciens il a fait
une espèce de grosse synthèse en
proposant d'autres choses c'est un
auteur qui a été très prolifique
c'est clair donc jeu de mots
séquentielle séquentiel parce que il ya
ce côté tout est organisé en fait tout
est pensé à la façon quasiment
mathématiques quoi exact mais faut pas
trop s'attarder dessus et vous ne dites
pas dans une copie que la pensée quand
tu es séquentiel c'est un heureux hasard
que ce soit à peu près vrai mais ça fait
partie des choses que c'est pour la rime
dévoile actuellement
donc son prénom c'est emmanuel est
pareil si l'on l'écorché je pense qu'ils
sont pas des vrais ressemble allemand
les couilles il a vécu à königsberg
toute sa vie sa sortie de connexions wi
voilà et il est vraisemblablement mort
puceau ans a toujours solo jamais je
sers je critique la raison pure il a
sorti un bouquin critique de la raison
pure et ensuite il a sorti un autre
bouquin critique de la raison pratique
le premier c'est sur la connaissance
donc que puis-je savoir et le second
c'est sur la morale que puis-je faire
il a sorti un troisième bouquin pour
info ouais critique de la faculté de
juger vérité morale jugement
universalité nécessité ya que ça de vrai
ça c'est en gros c'est la
caractéristique de la vérité pour quand
en vérité universelle nécessaire
exactement 7 + 5 égale 12 c'est un des
exemples phares de kant que je vous
laisserai checker vérité patrick news
voilà c'est juste qu'en gros il cherche
la vérité
j'enchaîne la raison pratique c'est vrai
que juste ça avait l'air débile c'est +5
égale 12 mai quand tu m'a expliqué le
truc un peu en détail c'est intéressant
donc allé voir a priori changement de
tactique parce que le a priori la est
hyper important c'est un mot clé chez
quand je veux pas d'hypothétiques
impératif catégorique parce que pour lui
la morale doit obéir à l'impératif
catégorique en grand une fois j'ai fait
une vidéo sur kant qui parle de ça de
l'impératif catégorique je voulais en
descriptions et donc pour qu'une action
soit morale en gros ce que j'ai retenu
c'est qu'il faut qu'elle soit
juste a priori c'est à dire en dehors de
toute expérience sachez que si vous
écrivez à priori a posteriori dans vos
copies attention à ne pas mettre
d'accent grave sur le à puisque c'est
une locution latine
évidemment merci pour la précision voilà
merci beaucoup je vous en prie pascal on
avoue on a évoqué deux choses avec
pascal c'est très long le truc parce que
le flou façon pnl fait qu'on prend
vraiment le temps il ya deux idées
importantes chez pascal la première
chose c'est le pari est il un dieu j'en
fais le pari le pari de pascal c'est de
miser sur l'existence de dieu en gros on
a tout à voilà si vous gagnez vous
gagnez tout donc on a tout à gagner si
vous perdez vous ne perdez rien
seulement la croyance pour lui c'est pas
non plus une affaire de jugement et de
jugeote sait pas on va pas décider s'il
admet que la raison exactement on va pas
décider tiens je crois ça il explique
par cette phrase qui est souvent prise à
contresens qui est le coeur a ses
raisons que la raison ignore c'est à
dire c'est pas ta part tu as tête que tu
veux être croyant c'est pas par le
raisonnement que tu vas voir une vraie
foi et il ya une dissociation entre la
raison et la foi
pareil pour le pari de pascal ya une
vidéo qui a été fait je vous l'amènerai
et moi j'ai fait une vidéo sur un pote
pascal de paris mais ce deuxième
thématique abordée dans le couplet sur
de pascal le calme calme calme moi
j'aime le calme calme comme le
divertissement divertissement au sens
premier du terme au sens étymologique
c'est à dire tout ce qui nous détourne
comme une diversion
mettez tourner de quoi payer mais qui
nous détourne de l'essentiel
exerçant et pour lui ce divertissement
ça nous rend malheureux et
d'où cette phrase qui est une citation
en fait qui nous sur laquelle on a
terminé le rap qui est tout le malheur
des hommes vient d'une seule chose qui
est de ne pas savoir demeurer au repos
dans une chambre exactement au repos
pour bien affronter en face la pensée de
la mort exactement mais qui fait partie
de la vie et donc qu'ils n'ont pas
quelque chose qui doit terminer et te
pourrir
d'après pascal ou encore une fois sous
encore une fois si vous voulez en savoir
plus je vous mets une vidéo en
descriptions voilà j'espère que c'est
plus clair pour vous j'espère que vous
avez qui fait je dois vous et qui fait
le sont enfin je dois vous avez appris
des trucs c'est quand même le principal
oui parce que c'est ça en fait on se
sert de la musique et aux arts toute
blague à part comme un support de
fixation de la mémoire mais je voulais
remercier aussi p de m'avoir donné
l'occasion de rire ce projet et tous
hyper cool donc voilà si voulez en
savoir plus déjà sous les réécouter
l'europe voilà je vous le lait en
descriptions sous les voir la chaîne de
bpvf et pleins d'expérience musique moi
j'adore ce mec je suis assez fan en fait
voilà je remercie toutes celles ci
voulaient en savoir plus sur la philo il
ya la playlist des coups de fil qui vous
intéressait et aussi la playlist de
philo sur la chaîne d'antisèches
montrait les sujets différemment en
thématiques que je vous mets aussi voilà
et bon courage
bon courage love peace comme on dit au
théâtre
merde sort des moines t-bone us juste on
voudrait revenir sur le rap philo 1
il ya des choses qu'on revenait en
commentaires et vous avez la plupart du
temps raison mon ami je sais qu'une
chose je ne sais rien n'indique c'était
plate ont effectivement c'est socrates
le truc c'est que socrate n'a rien écrit
donc c'est une parole qui est attribué à
socrate mais qui a été écrit par platon
voilà si tu veux c'était plutôt que de
faire un couplet sur socrate qui aurait
été je sais qu'une chose ne sait rien
fin du couple est on l'a mis dans le
dans le
coupet platon on s'est permis peut-être
une licence abusive en tout cas sachez
que cette phrase est de socrate
voilà donc dans votre copie ne m'étais
pas entre guillemets platon machin cité
socrates les sites et socrate et ben tu
n'as rien à faire devant cette vidéo
exactement c'était socrates c'est
incroyable ces fouilles à jour
rencontrer et votre chose que les
derniers petits trucs sur nietzsche
c'est quand on a dit oui je suis
peut-être un nihiliste mais moi au moins
je crois en toi
alors oui j'y crois en toi sûrement m'a
vraiment ni liste way au contraire il un
peu combattu ça voilà donc il ya var du
nihilisme way parle d'une ultime des
thématiques de ce bon vieux friedrich
donc moi ah ah ah ah ah je sais pas
comment s'excuse ouais enfin je suis
vraiment désolé ses excuses n'ont qu'un
temps fait mieux parce qu'on vous voilà
vous comme ça les à votre écran elle va
zy rap un peu sur nietzsche non mais
c'est bon les jours de faire des notes
angoissante
donc voilà on voulait juste revenir là
dessus parce que
parce que vous l'avez fait remonter et
vous avez raison échappé à notre oeil
vigilant
je suis désolé pour la faute
d'orthographe à la rousseau c'est vrai
j'avais pas vu j'ai pu
voilà on vous embrasse très fort bisous
bisous bisous